c'est un homme profond c'est quelqu'un
qui en doute parce que la question c'est
est-ce une avance qui drague session
mais son accession au second tour tout
est encore possible quand vous regardez
que 25% des électeurs ne sont pas encore
décidé quand vous voyez que on a encore
une marge de manoeuvre aussi sur
l'abstention
pendant sa marche vous savez que jean
lassalle a fait une marche importante
5500 km entre la france en 2015
d'ailleurs eric emmanuel macron de le
piquer l'idée 1 ben oui je confirme
l'idée de la marge c'est véritablement
ce qu'a fait jean lassalle j'ai pas
souvenir que monsieur macro et beaucoup
marché sur l'ensemble du territoire
mais bon en tout cas au cours la
question fondamentale que pose
effectivement jean français sur ce qu'il
apporte que dans cette campagne
aujourd'hui il apporte un renouveau jean
lassalle n'est l'héritier de personnes
jean lassalle c'est un homme politique
qui sait au fur et à mesure
non pas fabriquer mais aguerris à cette
vie politique il n'est pas non plus un
extrémiste vous voyez bien qu'il est
dans une position extrêmement centrale
et que par conséquent sa vocation à
rassembler existe véritablement et il
n'est pas non plus comment je pourrais
dire on peut pas lui reprocher d'avoir
les mains dans le pot de confiture non
plus et ça vous savez bien c'est un
homme honnête et quelles que soient les
façon dont on regarde sa vie politique
et quelle que soit la façon dont on
essaye de la tordre on trouvera pas des
choses qui sont répréhensibles